Kimball Walker has helped this team to
kind of turn the tide three on the money
for a lookout this is all Lucca and it's
not an easy step back whatever happens
he just continues to point will step
back action he's missed that shot a
couple of times tonight but still with
the same confidence in the same wheel to
draw to play that's one of his favorite
moves to that little step-back entire
career with the Los Angeles Clippers
there's that stick back three pointer
tourists well just a little up fake and
that is his patented move that was
charging the province $2.00 jacket stops
on the bounce shot bacon lots of dry
hits
giving inside one of his favorite shots
two-stepped a late clock situation here
for Lucca and a step back over back
three-ball how's this well when you back
off and that's what Rubio was doing just
forcing them to kind of take that shot
[Music]
concerts just Smith driving it on
Lillard then it's got 5,000 Smith
slipped he paddled Mooka
look up
[Applause]
great step back three Smith lost his
footing and then here's Luca heart this
tremendous ability to stay on balance
after stepping back
to have the strip to get that shot up
that's not necessarily an easy shot it's
just a great offensive place
[Music]
Lucca averages seven pull jump shots per
game and shoots 41% now that may not
sound like a lot
pardon missed one that's the state of
affairs in the last 30 seconds with
Houston having an eight-point lead then
cut to five and now to Terry the first
leaf removed he gives a big on it
steps back on capela screen by DeAndre
capella switched on DeLuca
[Applause]
and then this one more put a roadie yo
you say if you don't know now you know
back to Luke who was seven now on the
shot clock watch Donovan jump on him in
the corner Luca with a rattling chemical
water three but he makes those
nobody's business half the first shot
Luca chosen to put it on the dead eight
points they may need something really
special out of him again tonight
he works against cauley-stein
be the beginning in something special
Donald ari got picked off gotcha
oh my step back ten five hits the fray
Luca dark church look at the thrust on
that step back because he actually
penetrates take there's dodge it's
[Applause]
spires from teeth unfazed
Luca Dante she defied LA has
[Applause]
body laws to step back they love it with
Lucas on the dance floor dip back there
it is behind the back and look at that
follow-through nice stroke yeah take a
few extra steps shot clock at four
seconds down to three it's hardened time
has to force and when he gets off folks
that's the way it is here's good defense
by the Pacers daddy is young all over
but James about five feet behind the
line
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the last couple of years but has not hit
it
[Applause]
in charge with a step back free and it's
rule
nasty watch the step back by Harden just
enough not a chance for the Rockettes
dance has to deal in heart and I step
back he's selling for that one and hit
it in rhythm no for James sorry
everybody looks for hard as soon as I
get a rebound or summer there's James
again James again son stopping that's
why he was last years MVP Rockets on a
sick soul run on that play both guys to
determine to get a play for their team
hardly
[Applause]
[Music]
Hartman step back in pliers and gives
the Rockettes their first lead in the
play when we come back he'll shoot free
throws right now he makes his third
three in a row
but they cut hard enough tonight but
they forgot all about Chris Paul
I think he's reminding him that I can
still score fellas so much fun to work
with
terrific Oh put on a free talk about
terrific that's James Harden a starters
with 10 apiece Richardson and Tyler
Johnson from the something so important
especially one the weeks where you have
the guards that's the change little
health institutions Jalen Brown Joey
Rose here coming in but now they take a
timeout they've been able to keep him
off the line step back for a lot of
these teams is how much should you be
trying to contest that's clearly a foul
to me you can't contest that you can't
be lunging forward easy ones around the
rim
are going with a step-back three got
another one shaking his head look at it
Milwaukee's bench saying you can't guard
me now for the last seven in a row for
Houston how much you can do against that
number of touches that harden gets per
game Zappa gets another one here this
one of the keys is going to be from Mike
D'Antoni as he knocks down another three
on looks at Chris Paul since I got your
back and plays at a very slow pace
compared to the rest of League in the
bottom five but they can run they have
always had a half-court answer in NBA
history with 11 straight games of
makings five or more three Tucker just
hit the ball moments ago came to this
game to a 20 over his last three games
Tucker tonight one A two that's a three
by James Harden Arges AP's going at one
another
[Applause]
jelly heart
it's a fiddling shot look at all the
dancing
[Music]
crossover
here comes James step
between the ears James Harden again
putting on a show a step back three to
tie the ballgame and that's the problem
if you're Andre the doll you can't wait
for the call or try to flop challenge by
Evan Turner switching is Amita Barton
using a lot clock getting off the 380
Cup James Harden drills the three 14
seconds it's already down to seven step
back by Harden again
absolutely